ces questions quelle pierre la boîte de
sardines introuvable je sais pas si vous
l'avez trouvé des beaux-arts merci merci
en fait je n'aurais pas dû le dire allez
jean luc une question comme chaque
semaine jean-luc lemoine des clips tout
ce qui se passe dans cette émission
grâce aux questions des gens de la rue
c'est parti josé c'est une question qui
vous concerne ça m'arrange mais pas que
vous allez la question tout de suite
bonjour je m'appelle béatrice j'ai lu
que cyril hanouna et et la 45e
personnalité préférée des français
devant françois hollande qui est 49e
donc s'il est élu en 2017
je voulais savoir s'il comptait donner à
jean michel maire
le ministère de la turn
oui ça se pose à ce propos il n'aura
même si je suis pas élu je pense et
c'est vrai qu'on peut se poser la
question béatrice car c'est un vrai
sondage un cyril et ses modestes pour ne
pas le dire mais il est de plus en plus
populaire auprès des français et c'est
normal parce qu'il est proche des gens
de notre public par exemple il trouve
toujours un sûrement adaptés à chacun
que comme ici le spectateur le plus
célèbre
regardez comment il est accueilli
d'habitude
oh
buzizi chic dans le public il a aussi
beaucoup cue ball hoëbeke ou couilles
nous sommes une famille tout simplement
alors pour ce qui est du ministère
première jean-michel je ne répondrai pas
car je veux pas caricaturer mon ami le
baroudeur ah oui déjà qui m'en veut si
si regardez ont regardé le la semaine
dernière au moment des quatre tirs
bruno solo qui a joué mon cadeau reste
séquence on embrasse fort bruno
heureusement qu'il était là bruno fait
de la peine
oui jean michel truc que je caricature
en faisant croire qu'ils ne parlent que
de ça alors est ce vraiment de la
caricature pour répondre le plus
objectivement possible et faire mon mea
culpa c'est juste chercher dans les
émissions de la semaine dernière si la
méthode qu'il a 21 ans et la prohibition
quoi est elle capable
oui exactement j'ai fait bouger le
plateau à chaque fois que tu peux avoir
des grandes jambes c'est chiant et gros
stock de jean michel qui était pourtant
équipé à l'instant pour l'instant entre
temps on va se pencher sur eux
mais qui est tête de cheval génial c'est
que ces points l'eau dans le gaz est
sorti qu'une tête de cheval gérait pas
de la lune passant scénario cage cary
comme moi je veux quelque chose
alalalala oui en fait c'est un langage
top pour jean-michel c'est comme je
trompe fait pour les intimes ça sert à
tout ça ça n'a rien de vulgaire un nom
ne vous en faites pas les réponses mais
ne plaisait pas trop jean michel carles
avantage d'avoir une réputation de
séducteur c'est qu'on a un traitement de
faveur
la semaine dernière c'était la journée
des câlins donc on s'est fait des câlins
pas mais on n'a pas tous été logés à la
même enseigne
cette rentrée à des jeunes filles pour
les câlins
michel
jean-michel les votants
on avait pris mille défis pour
jean-michel pendant que moi je me tape
et gilles verdez j'ai rien contre j'aime
et à des moments j'ai un bien être
obsédé de la bande bon après cette
animation
les filles sont repartis ah oui c'était
pas vrai c'est que de la télé mais ça
jean michel n'avait pas compris donc à
la pause par deux suivantes ça la
feuille de service 1 mais bon
non de services que nous avons à
patricia sarrio tous les jours oui elle
tous les genres qu'interviennent avait
du boulot la mairie
david yala c'est pas possible
mais la question qu'on peut se poser
c'est jean-michel at il eu un vrai coup
de foudre ce jour là pas du tout il fait
ça que jean-michel quand il croise
plusieurs filles ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de jouer un monsieur patate
je laisse à mon jeu ou leur numéro
tous les gens qui interviennent n'ont
pas peur stylet chauffeur est la foule
chroniqueur andrew zucker séoul
il est horrible c'est mon idole
nouvelles idées après c'est moi qui
exagère un passe les détails mais il n'a
jamais retrouvé les numéros il a essayé
d'embourber notre rédac'chef julien avec
une excuse ni non mais digne de noir de
8 ans
regardez c'est pas vrai j'adore les
coordonnées
quel est ce qu'on n'a pas prête et
habite au moins était tentant de jouer
dehors des blancs
scusez l'excusé devrais m'en excuser de
désolé je n'invente pas tout ça mais
quand même ils étaient choqués en fait
de nos profs julien lalande qu'on
embrasse fort l'oreille ami d'enfance et
traumatisé ah oui il en compterait
maintenant à meredith était en fait
s'affaisser c'est quoi son problème à
jean-michel tout de suite la vie de
notre sexologue ceux qui en parlent
beaucoup tu fais en général ceux ci
soient si vous reprenez toi même lettre
soit c'est du pays agité mais mois
d'errance des fois ça déteint sur toi tu
t'es plein toutefois qu'il ait des
problèmes d'érection met en travers
mais moi ce que laisse et l'installent
c'est le phrasé du gard et de méthode
rigueur dirait une pub vous savez qu'on
voit là prévu ni quand mais c'est quoi
une direction des émissions de france 2
c'est pas gentil ça je crois qu'il ya un
contentieux entre un oui oui en fait il
me semble que gilles jamais digéré cette
fameuse conversation sur le ski de fond
avec jean michel eeckhout ce jour où il
a ouvert la porte de son jardin secret
tu es laisser son pour descendre les
abus ou sous début non on la revoit
pas bon score c'est le script son
transport
ce qu'ils font perdre
j'étais pas mon bon quand j'étais jeune
et l'elysée voulait me tourne est rare
et plus de concurrents
j'ai pas voulu
mais pas longtemps ajouté
ça y est les vacances et vous vous avez
remarqué jean-michel merde mais vous en
foutez total moi je n'ai pas non plus de
cas passionnant faux excuse moi je vois
depuis gilles ne fait plus de
confidences à jean-michel et c'est
dommage car je peux le dire aujourd'hui
c'était un accident
oui jean michel adore quand ses voisins
lui parle de de sport et surtout de leur
sport
c'est triste
la pauvre isabelle hains le suivant
c'est mon préféré
non mais tout le monde s'en fout de ces
histoires heureusement peut se rabattre
sur les invités comme ici philippe
besson a acquis elle racontait le jour
où elle a eu la télé
ah la la
le pen à oui c'est ça oui odeur et sans
jouer c'est une scène de film ça mais
c'est vrai que les gens s'en foutent
totalement récusée par les invités ont
été un truc dont je me foutais aussi un
ballon tu sais pas aujourd'hui pour lui
non finalement isabelle n intéresse
personne aller en vrai que maintenant
non mais non mais moi aussi en tout cas
la semaine dernière valérie bénaïm a
remplacé avec brio cyril hanouna rick
faut dire qu'elle pouvait compter sur
nous et en plus c'est vrai que je suis
accompagné de mes copains que j'adore et
qui sont avec moi comme le support qu
est ce qu on veut pas dire qu'on a un
peu on sème on est des frérots on sent
prête dès lors
hommage à jean marc généreux la danse de
la semaine on la doit bien des visas à
il a même un nom gilles verdez gilles
verdez après la danse des épaules voici
la danse des mains de m6 gilou
c'est par ces paroles
alain delon et pour finir la
conversation surréaliste du jour
pensez-vous syrie qu'en 45 secondes on
peut parler dans la même conversation de
chat avec de musique de temps partiel
n'en faire l'amour de danse d'écharpés
de grand corps malade
non c'est pas possible normalement non
joe si vous avez isabelle errants michel
côte à côte
et quand tu es chez toi tant dans la
musique de pareilles je dois pas
à vous danser tous les deux
chez laurie avec son écharpe
jacques décha devrait bientôt validant
ses deux boutons avant ça
je viens de l'apprendre
suivent le rythme
il m'a pas toujours techniquement mais
j'ai hâte au maton marivin vitesse de la
musique en fonction de ce que ces grands
corps malades de ne pas faire l'amour du
slam
mm
j'aimais la sortie normale aujourd'hui
un grand corps malade moi j'adore court
6 1 c à vous écouter surtout le parle
pas des raisons ça a duré cinq minutes
ce sont des rats consciemment élocution
aujourd'hui à l'aller c'est pas bon jour
je m'appelle marie louise je voudrais
juste savoir si c'est vraiment une
histoire sérieuse avec fatou parce que
sinon je me le tape très bien gilles
verdez